the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
[Music]
[Music]
everybody to round three of the 2022
summer chess classic to bring you all of
the action i am grand master alejandra
ramirez here with my analyst grand
master christian carrillo alejandro
always a pleasure to be here in studio b
with you we have two amazing tournaments
what can you tell us about these
tournaments alejandro they're not quite
the same field cup and they're not quite
the us champs but we do have very strong
fields for you two 10-player round-robin
tournaments full of grand masters full
of excitement it's one of the projects
that we are very proud to have here at
the st louis chess club tournaments that
help players become elite that small
step that they need between the 2600 or
even grand master path to the top of the
world there's not a lot of events there
they can play each other very often and
this is one of the great ones players
are as you can see dying to play in this
event and let's take a look at what we
have in group a for you as we already
have two rounds on the books uh three
players are on plus one they've won one
more game than they've lost you young yi
benjamin gladua and jonas beer from
denmark all have one half points uh
please play for fourth we have abhimanyu
mishra sam savion ray robson and aram
hacobian who actually saved a very
difficult end game yesterday against sam
savion with the white pieces and tied
for eighth position we have elias mirin
nicholas teodoru and the third seed
going into this event gregorio parrin
who lost with the white pieces against
the leader of the tournament yu yangyi
and how about the big group alejandro in
the big group we have a similar
situation it's two not three people that
are at the top and they also have a plus
one score both camille dragoon and
brandon jacobson half one and a half
points out of two
absolutely but unfortunately we don't
see it right there there we go there we
go
and jeremy is christopher you jj
alimorandi and antipa perkins
by the way actually has two decisive
games having lost the first game and won
the second i have to say alejandro i'm
quite impressed with your memory without
actually seeing the standings you remain
you remember the standings and how about
the tournament format tell us a bit
about that easy enough as you can see
some shots from the playing hall we have
two 10-player round-robin events nine
rounds each 90 minutes for the first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game at normal classical time control
with a 30 second increment all
throughout schedule is very easy we'll
have one round a day starting every day
at 1pm not here at the same with chess
club actually just around the corner
from the simulated chess club our
schedules will be around one round a day
every day at 1pm except
for the friday round
absolutely the last day will actually
start two hours earlier at 11am and our
show our live show starts every single
day two and a half hours later so right
now for us is 3 30 central time and what
about the social media alejandro how can
the audience reach out to us and
interact well join us we are paying
attention to the chat both on youtube
and on twitch and remember that if you
are donating on twitch also we are on
twitter and hashtag somewhere chess
classic but if you're donating on twitch
join us for every 75 dollars that we get
with subs or donations we'll be able to
provide a full semester of chess
programming to a kid here in st louis so
certainly a lot of support being given
to chess not just to the elite and not
just the grand masters but for players
of all levels here in st louis to join
us in this initiative it's 75 dollars
for every 75 that we get we will be able
to provide a full semester of chess
programming for a talented student here
not only any type of chess programming
but actually with top level coaches
that's right we actually have one
volusia nacobian a good friend of ours
here in saint louis who is doing a lot
of the bulk of those training so your
kid can get the best training possible
here in the united states and alejandro
what can you tell us about the pairings
round number four it's what we're here
for it's abby manuel mishra with only 13
years of age she'll be facing up against
adam hakobian elias mirren is playing
against grisha o'farrin
theodoro in a grudge matches actually
playing as benjamin gladura benjamin
ladura lost a crucial game against
theodore in the finals of the collegiate
national championship the final four uh
about a month and a half ago and i'm
sure that he's coming back for vengeance
sam sevien is playing against jonas beer
is trying to get his first full point
and but the marquee matchup will
certainly be in the highest rated
pairing today yu yang yi versus ray
robinson yi already on a plus one score
ray not fighting his strike just yet uh
drew a really boring game yesterday
against abhimanyu mishra he tried to you
know make it interesting and it was
seemed like he was going to go that way
in a batman next semi slot but it really
petered out to nothing very quickly also
not a complete disaster for raymond
in the first round he actually had the
black pieces against oparion oh that's
true he drew quite easily yeah now yu
yang gi on the other hand he drew the
first round with the white pieces in a
very shaky game and he was telling us
yesterday during the interview that he
felt like he was just probably losing in
that one but then he came back he
bounced back with the black pieces with
a huge victory yesterday against
grigorioparin who unfortunately for him
right now is struggling but let's not
forget we still have seven rounds yeah
we have a bunch of rounds left of course
we have this one uh let's not focus on
analysis just yet let's actually go
into the pairings of group b first
because today i think that group b is
slightly more exciting than group a
group b we have a bunch of games there i
think the marquee matchups plural um are
going to be kamel right and antipov but
also like the julian ciao game uh who
just comes up two decisive games against
brandon jacobs and one of the leaders is
certainly up there the other leader
camille dragoon against the depot though
you have to look at that one but i
wanted to start today's broadcast
actually looking at the game between the
general i'm sorry not gamerose nicolas
and christopher you uh these are two
very young players nicolas czecha is a
college student he goes to yale
university i believe he's a
sophomore yeah he's about to be a rising
sophomore is what we call them yes and
uh christopher you well he hasn't even
graduated high school actually um
quite young but it seems like a lot is
going on on that game so let's just jump
straight into it perhaps we can uh pull
it on our screen right now as you can
see the playing hole wow a lot of things
are actually happening in that one i'm
glancing
and to be honest i have no idea what's
happening i see this last move queen to
d3 and i see a hanging knight on e5 and
i'm like wait wait wait a minute that's
not how you play chess
you are just defending that knight on e5
where are you going with the queen um
what if i just simply take so this is
the main question right if we go out
moves just to tell the audience what's
going on after the moves uh queen g3
g3 a couple moves ago just two
yeah
i felt that this is already the start of
incredible tactics because black is up
two points which is a lot
but currently i have a very direct
threat g7 is made and of course i'm also
threatening the bishop on f3
so that's why they uh black played the
move 95 which might be the only way to
defend everything intercepts the bishop
as well as defends uh the bishop on f3
now the question is
what if i just simply take like this
i think the problem with this move is
queen e3 chuck oh okay so you started
with queen e3 yeah start with queen e3
rook after is the only move and then
take and at the end of all this stuff
the night is nice that's why he started
with knight to c3 yeah knight c3 hits
the queen
if you go to f5 for example i think
and then i take on f3 so that's not
really that's easy that's easy take you
actually take back first because the
knight on c3 is hanging then you take
one f3 you're a piece up and you're
going to win this one yeah so he goes to
d3 and this is where we need to actually
calculate because much more aggressive
approach you have to keep connection
with the pawn on e3
but still the question is what if i just
simply take on e5 and you take here i go
rook to f2 i don't have any other
alternatives you take only five most
likely i guess so yeah and then i take
on f3 isn't that
a piece for how many points
it is a lot of pawns okay so it's not
that bad it really is not that bad i'm
actually wondering if there's a better
move just for one second if you can go
back
well actually there definitely is a
better move because he just played it
yeah he played rook f3 i was wondering
about bishop takes e5 but perhaps
we should play c5 first
yeah but this is what we were looking
for i can make it work i'm trying to
find a move that's not
softer queen 33 what yeah it has to be
queen e3 right there's nothing else
right rook f2
and i don't see anything yeah yeah
there's nothing and once you attack and
try to get well first of all your bishop
is hanging yeah you don't have that and
queen to g6 is met nicely quinto g3 okay
so he decided against that he decided
against that end game with three pawns
for the pieces yeah instead he goes for
the position with two pieces
against a rook but by the way there is
no checkmate on g7 because firstly there
is a check
so you have to respond to that you take
on f3 and i'm not
i don't actually know how do we assess
this well i have to say at first glance
white just seems to be much better yeah
mostly because of this guy i i have to
agree that you're gonna get a pawn back
right knight takes d5 is hard to prevent
i'm also going to go rook to f1 f1 right
d1 is coming i mean you're not going to
take d5 anytime soon you can take it
whenever
um not in a hurry and the king is safe
right that's the problem another huge
problem for black right now for example
if you go something like queen to g6
not only that my king hides but also i'm
creating an extra threat i want to go
rook to g1 next and you're actually
losing instantaneously now i have rook
to f1 coming rook to g1 coming
and knight takes d5 with devastating
consequences so this looks terrible so i
don't see it so maybe black is just
nearly busted here that's
to the naked eye this is what it looks
like this is one yeah remember we're not
using engines so we might be completely
blundering something but
this looks i don't think we are i know
this looks very bad for black
yeah right yeah i i like this uh
decision of taking taking on f3 over the
end game with the three pawns you can
just click on it at the end uh the line
with bishop takes e5
little up um yeah bishop takes c5 this
one no no
no yeah yeah level
so bishop takes c5
oh yeah yeah sorry
park buck this one right
yeah i have to say the other one looks
better because it's much better first of
all
this is a three result game where's the
knight going yeah that's a three result
game you know you have to go by the side
then we know that knights on the side
not very good also i have a feeling that
if i get to the second rank
i feel like we're playing for all
results and the other one i think black
white is just you might have some
problems yeah yeah yeah that's a good
decision by chaka
excellent decision by cheka 26 minutes
for the young player from yale only 19
minutes and counting and a lot of moves
to make and a lot of difficult moves to
make for christopher you now
let's jump to this game between uh
the game of the day actually the game of
the day in uh group b uh between dragon
camille one of the leaders of the event
and misha antipov yeah michelle antipov
is playing his favorite groomfeld
actually i think he only plays the
groomfield
um and this variation i i haven't even
looked through the game but i know which
variation this is the variation
everybody's playing everybody's playing
nowadays yeah i don't know why but it is
i can guess why this line of the
groomfield is kind of drawish but white
never loses and sometimes wins even
though they're down two pawns yes and
what we are talking about is actually
this line
which was played if i'm not mistaken it
it wasn't sam actually yes it was
with the white pieces and then only a
couple of days later it wasn't a couple
of days it was just a few hours it was a
few hours later a few hours yeah samsung
played this in the grand prix i'm
actually blanking against two and that
same day yeah we had it here in the
spring chess classic at the same time
oh yes i remember now i remember now
actually against on people i guess on
typo
somebody's strong i want to say it was
like
i don't remember at the moment yeah yeah
but uh he has been playing this line he
has been defending the black side of
this line quite a few times in the last
few months and how is he holding him in
today's game he's up to pawns but nobody
really cares because opposite-colored
bishops and weak kings it's still up to
pawns
but yes i mean it matters much less than
you would expect yeah
um
now how did we get here first of all
this is the line of stuff
yeah
and all the way to this point i think a5
was
perhaps the idea that sam i think a5 is
the best move yeah and after bishop to
uh d4 to create this outpost for the
queen queen to b4 queen to a1 yeah you
still have one extra square there and
now it's all about the positioning of
the bishops
are you going to be able to find an
outpost for for the light square bishop
the bishop that will go to b5 so you did
find an outpost it's safe there but
unfortunately you're not on the king
side right you're on the queen side and
it's kind of stuck
there now what that will allow white is
to create some checkmating threats as we
are seeing after this couple of moves
bishop to h8 now you have to defend
against queen to g7 the only way to do
that is of course to go f6 and now e5
and we see this so the idea is that on
e5 there's no queen d3 i was wondering
why you're rna4 exactly yes very good
point alejandro so the what we're
discussing if you start with bishop to
h8 f6 e5 now i can just simply go queen
to d3 i still have a tempo on the bishop
and actually you're just losing
yes because now you have to exchange you
take i take back i don't even have it
this is just completely
no g5 at the end it is because
very nice
nicely pointed out
this bishop protects the pawn on h7
you're not going to be able to engage
this battery on the seventh rank so
looks quite good for black but camille
after
quite a thing actually 11 minutes he
played the move a4 and now we got into
this line
queen to a3 bishop to c2 bishop is
redirecting
to a more central position bishop to a4
f4
rook to d8
h3
rook to d7 k2 h2 rook to d8 and i think
this is the current position that we
have on the board let's try to analyze
it alejandra
[Laughter]
i mean my first instinct is that
it's such a hard position because did he
did he actually not play bishop g2 on
purpose
that is the problem yeah because now you
you take take take but unfortunately
your bishop is hanging at the end
um this is just losing
so first you start with rook to d8 now
actually you are threatening to go
bishop takes uh g2 because let's say i'm
just going to make a random move if you
go rook to d1 i still have this extra
square to f3 yeah and my recon this is
i i'm kind of curious if i play rook d1
here look rook cd1 let's go sure uh
i don't i don't think you can take on d1
right no no no i'm not going to take on
d1 so you're queen c4 i don't know why
actually i do know yeah i
i do know why because now you take only
seven but but you have rook
you know rook t7 d7 which one i think
the first one the rook one the
d710 no no no no no is going to do f6
first yeah
i have a feeling your king is going to
get in some sort of trouble i have a
feeling too even though
but maybe not i wouldn't guarantee it
right maybe not maybe maybe not but it
is very scary for black to play like
this i don't see the actual threat it's
it's very scary and i have a feeling
it's um
it's a game for one result yeah because
i always have to h8 queen to f6 you mean
two results but yeah two results yeah
yeah i agree
um this doesn't look very privacy for
black so you kind of have to go queen c4
and i would go into c4 and actually i
don't maybe it's not a problem i feel
i'm quite well protected
yeah i if the bishop gets to if your
trade rocks or if you try even one rook
and go bishop d5
i mean you're going to be pretty pretty
comfortable oh yeah oh yeah bishop to d5
first of all i have this huge threat
rookie d2 maybe rick dawes is not a good
move so i think black's doing okay maybe
rook to c5
rook c5 i think queen d3 is going to
come into d3 and we there's a lot of
repetitions like that right you can go
rook c3 yeah but i'm 100 sure who wants
to who's playing for a victory right now
i think it's still white
really i think it's still white because
because he always has these chances to
give him for petrol somehow i mean rook
c3 is not like black in
22 maybe
take this
yeah this might be
the perpetual against the queen it might
be uh i don't guarantee that black is
losing yeah by the way sorry that might
actually just finish it it might just if
he wants it right if he wants if he
wants it but that's the question i don't
know if black's fully equalized there's
still some tricks move the bishop
somewhere go queen b2 yeah so i'm sure
that camille will try
but
he might not have it he might not have
anything better than the draw well
there's another problem that camille is
facing right now and that he has only
seven minutes left for how many moves
nine moves but still seven minutes with
such complicated position in which you
do have yeah this rook c5 c3 very
tempting option
yeah and you are two pawns down it
doesn't feel doesn't feel like
you're going to i don't think he's going
to go for it i think he's just going to
uh go for equality
now
let's go to your students uh game
alejandro ali marandi versus haruti
union
no longer my student unfortunately for
me no longer your students
after six years tenure at saint louis
university got his master's degree one
of the founding fathers one of the
founding students
team actually came in in the first year
we had a team in 2016. has finally
graduated
how do you feel about that alejandro i
feel a little
mixed feelings you know like it was
about time
the cuckoo flew the nest but uh
you know it's always sad to see them to
sit and leave of course of course
but right now he has a better position
first of all i i think that a pawn has
to be giving white the advantage in
this situation
it has to be better yeah i i think so
and if you go king to d7 the problem is
that i just implemented the 95 is coming
so that might be a problem you cannot
approach uh this pawn very easily yeah
that being said what do you do to make
progress though
i'm not saying
he's winning or anything of that nature
i'm just saying that no but he's the one
president white's definitely better and
you have a lot of tries you can go rook
h1 you could go rookie one except
probably work somewhere
and put some pressure
i don't
know how much better he is but because
the port on a5 is pretty untouchable
and by the way another problem with the
time for uh the player with the black
pieces arrow the union three minutes and
15 seconds while uh your student quite
fast
41 minutes he plays according to his
brand now
let's move on to to group a alejandro
let's do it
let's continue we're going to go to your
student all right
so what's happening in the game between
glendura
and uh the other greater with the black
pieces
defending in this position
against the two bishops of the other
rules yeah this looks close to lost he
needs to first lost for black right
because you you're worried about knight
c6 just winning that's a big problem yes
yes so
so almost every end game you're going to
have to face nice and knight takes a7
and that's a problem that is a problem
and maybe losses and exaggeration but
white is definitely the one pushing here
you have two bishops you have more space
you have the knight coming to c6
it's maybe a defensible land game but it
looks really ugly um without a light
squared bishop
which is black is sorely missing
this knight on c6 is going to be a pain
untouchable it's pretty much untouchable
you don't want to create a passport on
c6 so you cannot really trade you do
have one trick as black so for example
[Music]
whatever yeah and then a5 now you can go
a6 actually okay i would like to go a6
because i want to get rid of one or one
of the pawns
a pair of pawns so you cannot take
because your knight is hanging
you have to wait for this queen to get
out of d6 uh out of the the attention of
the square c6 or
uh one of your pieces defending extra
defending that knight on c6 potentially
the queen on c4 okay
so
but what do we play right
here after all we do have to make a move
um as black
we're talking about the engines they're
really bad right oh he played knight e7
immediately that is
trying to defend this not only that but
also creating an immediate threat
on the pawn on d4
yeah
so what if i just simply go queen to c4
i have a kind of a dumb question
sure if i go
picture five a3
a3 okay i'll
i assume he wants to take it i'm not
even going to think twice yeah knight c6
how do we knight to c6 i have queen a1
yeah yeah i know you have queen a1 and i
still want to play this
at the end i do
let's let's try let's try to figure this
out so what do you do
see the problem here is let's just show
this to the audience yeah you take take
you want to take they take and i thought
i was promoting my point but you have to
check this
yeah
so can i do it with no but i don't want
to play bishop d1
although
if you have to go bishop d1 yeah
i don't believe this is
this is enough first of all
ah but i don't have
you have a lot of choices so if you take
take take
here's the seven points queen to c1 you
have queen to see two yeah
and there's no way to stop you from
promoting so that's a problem it does
look pretty artificial i don't believe
in it
very artificial
uh but first of all what if i just make
a random move like this and i'm back to
d5
tonight what
back to d5
yeah yeah maybe this is the correct way
yeah queen a1 is pretty annoying because
you do have
knight to c3 that you have to worry
about no no i agree i think black has
plenty okay i wanted to play king h2
when when when the bishop's on d1 yeah
it's not the same d1 is not enough
okay so bishop doesn't work well i don't
know bishop a3 i was also thinking queen
takes d4 bishop b2 here because i wanted
to take advantage of
your f6 knight somehow hanging maybe
something like knight takes g6 or knight
yeah knight g6 or even knight c6 maybe
depending on
where do i put my queen not so easy
right
okay let's go here
all right just to keep an eye on this
guy let's go g3 just to annoy you
okay
trying to annoy me
i'm hopefully succeeding
okay
let's keep contact
with uh the knight on f6 also yeah now
we have some ideas maybe now here i have
to go knight c6
finally
finally
finally you go to c6 okay
so what can we do right now
i gotta say this looks pretty dangerous
for black but also artificial for white
artificially yes yeah i'm gonna go here
yeah
so my plan is really take one a7 why i
went with this knight and not this one
is because i want to open up
this diagonal if you do take i'm going
to give you a check you're going to move
the king most likely somewhere and then
bishop to g7 and i couldn't
make a good way of dissolving this pin
yeah that's all i think it just was by
by the way queen to c4
this looks like a bunch of rubbish i
mean queen c4 is just the better move
just defend the party just defend the
floor sometimes simple
simple chase yeah stop thinking so hard
play a good move also after knight c6
you just never take you just cannot take
that yeah with the queen on c4 you just
cannot take it yeah so knight e6 is a
real threat
um
yeah i still really like uh
me too i think white also knight to e7
it does feel a little bit not artificial
but too passive yeah although i don't
know what else you could have done
yeah all right we'll give white an
advantage probably not that big but
still
big let's go to our uh
youngest competitor
youngest mishra versus jacobian mishra
the newcomer to the a group he won the b
group just a couple of months ago the
spring classic with actually
a very convincing performance he
finished with six and a half out of
seven that's really impressive for that
level of play
against grand master level competition
so that was quite impressive he punched
his ticket into the a group and right
now he's facing the big big boys and the
big boys indeed and the big boys like
jacob i don't think he's even 21.
um actually no he just turned 21. yeah
uh
what are we thinking about this position
optically i don't know what i think but
i almost never see a ram on
three minutes and counting and he's
20 minutes plus he's such a fast player
like
aram aram is a super fast player yeah
and he's having some actual difficulties
here with the clock management this is
move 23 by not even close to 40. not
even close no and this is a very
complicated position
i i feel i feel black is in a bit of
danger because i think so too it doesn't
have a lot of space
and it's hard to resolve the situation
in the center you don't want to play c5
and kill your own bishop you cannot play
d5 because it allows e5 you don't want
to take on d4 because it improves black
white structure
so
all the natural moves here
have a very big if mm-hmm
and that's when you start noticing that
perhaps your position is not so good you
i mean c5 bishop takes a4 is something
you don't really even consider you just
kill the bishop on a7 so badly yep
that's the problem i don't think you
agree i don't think you consider this
seriously
but what else do you do that's that's a
kind of annoying question you could go
like queen c7 he did he actually did
play queen zone but
you have to be a little careful that
bishop c4 doesn't work
okay bishop to c4 you probably have to i
think you have to go to d5 right you
cannot drop back you cannot draw back if
you drop back
just one two yeah this is just
completely over
um so you have to
play d5 okay i think d5 yeah but
but maybe it does work
well
it kind of has to work um if around
played or at least it has to be
complicated the way we refute it
so take take
and you're basically saying that if you
take
i think if you take i'm not having
compensation i have enough calm there's
also a possibility i get a pawn back
immediately
i mean i could take take close my eyes
and pray and play either
take on e1 and bishop a4 or bishop c6
and then take one after somebody cannot
ah my rook is saying sorry bishop e6
first yeah
so you have to start with bishop c6
but then i have been queen to c4 yeah
but after rook g6 we're playing for all
results yeah yeah now now this is a mess
yeah no absolutely there's a mess where
i don't know who's better you have some
compensation i have some you have an
extra ponder who cares and at least some
comp at least some company yeah we're
not going to say that it's full com but
but you got you got some tricks no but
ah there you go those are tricks that
you were talking about yep chocolates
take and i don't have counter check
okay
i like it i like the uh
so about the trend of this game we do
like mishra's position
and his time
situation a lot his time situation yeah
this is really good i have to say
um
his position might or might not be
better probably it is there's definitely
some pressure
his time management on the other hand
with only two minutes and 33 seconds
left for his opponent and so many moves
to play
i really like his chances i agree
all right let's see what savion is doing
against beer
the young dane who actually produced uh
a beautiful concept i have to say
yesterday yeah we were looking at the
game we were like okay black is
definitely putting some pressure on
white's king it does feel like white
might have this idea of going queen to
b3 queen to f3 and uh find the
repetition he said no no no he was a
fighting spirit even though he was low
on time and his king was pretty weak
yeah but he found he found ways he said
let's go with the king
out let's get out of the shell and
produce a very very beautiful concept um
what do we
what do we think about his position
right now i mean the main issue is he's
down material right uh he is down a pawn
and this boss are doing a pretty good
job because this pawns are keeping his
rooks at bay
objectively speaking
it seems to me that black doesn't have
enough here
enough compensation for equality not for
a pawn
you don't think so i don't think so
because i mean you cannot take on
you cannot take on g3 you could take on
g3 no way this works well it's queen d1
right
ah you have queen d1 which
keeps the game going right
but i don't know if you want to do that
actually why not kh2 i was thinking i
don't know the game continues
so you probably take now yeah
and you're the one
invading me first absolutely it's kind
of a mess but
that's a huge mess huge mess right you
cannot take most likely amazon queen g6
rook f7 queen
i have queen h5 at the end so if you go
here maybe i can even go here oh can you
take i have queen h5
yeah well we're going to pretend all of
that analysis was accurate
precise
at this point we're kind of just making
moves
because almost for sure there's better
options for both white and black now
initial position this is what we have
right now on the board
i don't know my instinct is why it's
better
but it's a pawn it's a it is it's a part
it's an important part because it keeps
the rooks at bay like if it was some
super pawn
maybe not we're talking about the pawn
on d3 yeah
just do not
create any confusion
um
do we have anything else as
[ __ ] no but i i really like
taking on g3 i think you kind of have to
yeah the more we look at it i don't know
i don't see another h3 for example i
think it's just going to be easily made
anyway
queen takes h3
makes no sense no
there's no way to open up the position
if you don't open up the position you're
in trouble
so that doesn't work
you it does feel like you have to take
otherwise i take on h4 myself i don't
think you have a choice
right so take
you have to give a check
always root hg7 is coming
with tempo and you most likely will get
checkmated
king
goes to h2
do we think of this move as a forced
move probably probably i don't think
you're going to have to ever
i also have this option
yeah i thought about it but then you
have rook h3 and then queen to f and
then eg3 and then i wasn't so sure
swinging around okay you could take on
f4 also
yes i can also do that but you take on
b7 yeah i i don't know
uh he played the move rook 8 d6
defending the e6 pawn i suppose
didn't initially like that because i
thought white would take on h4 but
perhaps he's not worried about just
takes queen takes
maybe
he has to take back yeah but but here
rook g3 i feel is even stronger than i
go here most likely in b7
i you can still think i can still take
that
i don't know if i like rookies not over
by any means i mean i can just still go
maybe create some
threats of my own
yeah this is kind of still a huge mess
though it is
it's such an unclear position
and how are we doing on time because
time is off the essence in all of these
games that we've seen so far they still
have some time 11 minutes for sam and 13
for jonas so still still winning some
so within like
some time pressure yeah not not crazy
time pressure and just to finish it off
with actually we haven't seen the game
of the hey
problem actually never mind the end of
the day is a dead draw
four versus three hours i'm going to
play this i'm gonna play this forever
you can play it as much as you want and
they will i guarantee you that you will
play this for the next 50 moves yeah but
it will not change the result of the
game probably this is
the easiest of the four versus four four
versus threes that you can get
is it yeah queen is the easiest this
exact uh configuration i don't know
about the exact configuration but in
general queen
with the pawn on h6 i know is quite easy
yeah but with the port on gf5 that's
just as easy file open yes probably just
as easy sure
it's done
this one seems to be uh it'll be a draw
i'll draw as well
oh the other one is wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait it's
similar no no but is this there's a draw
i understand it's a draw but how easy it
is
is the question yeah so i go f6 the
harder of the two
right yes
it's not that hard here and then get my
king to f4 yeah that's the thing you
never get there
well you have to defend the second rank
either no you're not
because then i go check
yeah i think you can allow me to be cut
in the second which is why this is a
draw
so what we're saying is that you can
basically just
wait i give a check
yeah and that's supposedly yeah at some
point the important thing is not to let
the king to f5 throughout k5 so
here let's say you give a check you cut
me on the first rank and it's kind of
sad for white right because i don't want
to go king g1 but if i go king e3 let's
say i put my king on f2
then nobody's defending h3 exactly so
you need to keep the king around this
pawn
yeah you need to defend all three
squares it's technically a draw but you
do lose it sometimes okay that's wide of
course he played rook to c5 now this is
ilya smiry um a very experienced player
i'm sure he's seen this end game before
um yeah i don't expect gregory to be
able to capitalize no he's extra pawn no
this one this one is not supposed to be
too hard
all right and
look at ilya he's he's not worried at
all
he's like okay this is over
we both know
the russian school has taught us that
this is probably
a draw it's technique technique to the
best of their abilities
all right uh what do you want to focus
on because we have gone around the world
in this one zhu zhang chao oh wait did
we not look at the game of the day we
have
not looked at the game of the day in the
b group zhu zhang chao against brandon
jacobsen
brandon won the first one drew the
second
zoo
drew the first one one second
yeah a very moved tournament so far for
joey and chow um how do we feel about
this position obviously this was a
king's indian
but unlike most kings unions black is
actually up two pawns somehow
that being said
two pawns two pawns
and white has two bishops how did white
manage to get the pawns up
no even even even weirder how the black
managed me
what is going on here
yeah white just kind of gave them away
okay
with the last two moves actually
let's see
so
aha so this was the okay c5 you give up
one pawn
quite an interesting and typical concept
d6 the problem is you're not actually
getting any of your pawns back
immediately yeah not immediately so i
wonder where the compensation is there's
a lot of moves here for white you could
take on c5 and queen b2 for example
you want to give me i'm going to give
you a third pawn i don't care because
here we have queen takes b7 okay so you
got one back yeah here knight f4 is a
threat so you don't watch out to two
yeah
so i have to go here
you don't have to but it seems like a
very good move
queen c6 i don't know i i feel like as
white has compensation absolutely no 97
what are we talking about
97 that's a problem yeah that's an issue
that is a problem
boom boom and this is game over that's
game over okay
so i have to be a bit careful about
your devious ideas
yeah it seems like
white has ideas right it's not it's not
an empty sacrifice this is definitely
something that's practically difficult
for black
okay
let's try to reroute this knight
i want to go to e6
but
you can take i can there's so many
things here to consider right because i
can also go g3
i don't know if it works but
you really want to travel no but
i trapped the knight at the end really
yeah does this work so take take check
king f2
f2 let's say king jude no no i can give
you a check no i have to
but i can give you a check first no f2
why do you want to go to f2 because on
knight takes e1 i don't like your knight
well i i get that but what i'm saying is
that i can give you a check first
oh oh i see i said so now you don't have
king f2
maybe i got king h1 anyway
no but nobody's defending g3 but now i
can just
skadoodle back to you and go back yeah
that's also true
yeah complicated situation uh 11 minutes
for the georgian ciao
and i do have this extra score yeah
even this i don't know how to
assassinate queen b7 who knows what's
happening yeah i feel like white isn't
worse than any of these lines despite
being down two pawns wild game wild game
yeah brandon bringing a lot of action to
this tournament typical brandon typical
typical brandon he likes to uh to fight
he likes to play his kings in the end he
likes to come up with new ideas that age
six which six round number one and then
your student followed up with the same
idea in the second round um
he has a lot of ideas he has a lot of
good ideas and it does seem like he has
a lot of experience with the king's
indian as well so this is a feared
weapon
that he brings to the table every single
game with the black pieces now i like
brandon and i like his his style of play
zhu zhanchao is also a very very
intriguing player and very experienced
player as well
now what do we think about
and there we have him
right now pondering his next
moves only 10 minutes left on the clock
for him
i would be confused too right well look
you just he's active you suck two puns
you cannot be confused right now you
need to have
a plan
did he miss queen to f8 was queen to f8
out of his reach i i don't think so no i
think it's just so many options because
he can take taking b2 but he also has
just every move available kind of
but okay let's just see how long he okay
he didn't think for uh for that that
long just kind of felt instinctively
that he had something here played c5
played d6 and now of course
the idea being that you actually cannot
place your queen anywhere else yeah yeah
but f8 if you go to e8 or e6 that's
going to allow knight to c7 with double
attack
if you go on the d file anywhere i'm
going to take on c5 and then you cannot
recapture back because knight to f6
comes or knight takes f4 specifically
queen design queen takes h5 is easier
but yes oh that's
that's even nicer i like it
yes same idea
knight goes to f6 you lose
now
and queen to the eighth as we were
mentioning take here quinto f8 has to be
played
so he definitely had it yeah he
obviously saw it beforehand probably he
got this position and thought here i'll
find something
uh but fine what i don't know queen d3
is actually not such a stupid move queen
to d3 yeah it has he has a threat
i mean
it's a real threat
g3 is a threat
hmm
i don't know if it's a good threat
probably not because 96
but 96 bishop b2
man it's such a weird position
so you're basically saying that you gave
up the pawns and now you're playing for
some sort of uh
i'm just chilling
i'm chilling two puns down they're not
my pawns
i like it
i feel black is better though
i don't think he's better
and i don't think he's better in the
initial position but
at least afterwards
um
still he's pondering his next option
because um
yeah this is a crucial moment let's let
him think here yeah uh because
vasquez and burke have like oh he
actually played took on c5 to c5 i'm
curious what he's going to do right now
he's going to think
commentators prediction is
i think i think
let's see
yes yes well said well predicted
christian kirilla thank you thank you
all right so what's happening in this
game that we actually have a scene game
between vasquez and guillermo i mean
material wise
sorry vasquez and burke
sometimes you play yourself yeah yeah uh
so materially
black is just busted down the exchange
in a pawn but
i'm assuming there's some sort of
compensation here i don't see it
but
maybe black is just lost
because at the moment the move rook b7
is a little bit of a threat that's a big
a bit of a threat
bishop h6 is also kind of a threat
your bottom d3 is not actually going
anywhere because d2 rook d1 among others
and you cannot take on h3 because among
other things queen d5 is just resigns
the same game is hopeless
exchange up and to connect to passwords
no way you're going to survive this um
this looks lost that's problematic and
you only have four minutes to solve this
puzzle you cannot
try to move the rook
on the f uh file and create any sort of
threats because rook takes p8 is coming
i don't even defend what do you do
bishop to d5 not possible not possible
no i i think why it's just winning
yeah
this might be it like if you go rook to
d8 or b7 just finishes the big problem
i still have bishop to c7 but i have a
feeling bishop
even rook c1 d2 bishop takes d2 is
probably winning
oh yeah that's for sure that's for sure
that is for sure yeah yeah yeah i mean
we're going to enter in this
you don't even have to calculate rook
one no checking no checks no
no just do it easy way no checks for you
i have two extra pawns on the queen side
this is nice
um
so what do you do
i think he's dead i actually don't see a
move i actually do think he's dead
vasquez vasquez huge victory for him
this would be um he started off with two
troops
two draws
quite a difficult game in the first
round against uh michonne depot i
actually don't remember what happened in
the second round for him i would assume
it was quite uneventful but right now
he does i'll take a look
he does pile on the pressure on his
young opponent and actually pier at the
collegiate level as well that's true
they actually
yeah even though they're different
generations kind of
vasquez is still a collegial player he
plays for universities he's texas at
dallas finishing his masters
and
burke is i believe a sophomore at
webster he's in um i think
junior right junior something right now
yes rook to d8
yeah time flies alejandro
um
rook to d8 rook to b7 this is what we
actually looked at just a second ago
bishop to c7 and now we just said rook
to c1 probably finishes the game very
easily easily
if you do go bishop to b d5 the problem
is i take take and you're a piece down
at the end of it yeah that's a lot
no even without the bishop i'm winning
you're probably winning right without
the bishop idea
but
with the okay
the bishop is over um but what do you do
i think it's over
ah wait no never mind well you thought
bishop h2 now yes i had the same thought
i had the same grandmaster thought where
you think like bishop is a discovery now
but it didn't work in the previous move
there's no reason it would work this way
yeah yeah the rook was protected move
ago is protected now
um
yeah
yeah i i don't see it simple to b7 might
finish the game by the way we are being
told by our producer that jj alimurani
has found a very nice tactic it's
actually move 40 so let's jump into that
i don't see the tactic goodness what is
going on
he just played the move knight d3 g5 e6
jettisoning
a very important pawn let's not let our
producer to
shame us into not finding this tactic
what is the
what is the follow-up here
where is it
okay i see an idea i mean i see an idea
of like a6 right and then you cannot
take the pawn but i don't see what you
do after k7
no i'm actually thinking about
maybe give a check first
on
and no but this would be to come
that's too artistic uh rook to h6 rook
a6 rook a8 i basically just want to get
the rook to eight and then no don't be
so artistic i think there's something
more direct because rook h6 is pretty
dangerous right rock h6 king
d7 i guess king d7 then i can go right
to e5 it doesn't matter you're 95 anyway
oh yeah this
should be this should it looks very
dangerous
this looks like the correct path no no
no the thing about this move
is that maybe you got a6
you have a lot of things i think this is
just done yeah problem is knight geez
and if you do go king to e8
i mean at the very least knight c6 is
winning
you know you're not you're not catching
that yeah you're not catching that the
only way you can catch it is wait for me
to go 86 oh e6 nice move nice boy jj
nice find by jj and actually he's not
that bored right now yeah it doesn't
move 40 so he reloaded with an extra
half an hour
so the tigran
well i would say only the ground
reloaded wait an extra half an hour
because jj still has 20 minutes left he
thinks a great move i like this move a
lot
perfect all right so we're going to let
uh jj find the right continuation
definitely looks quite winning after
either even knight to e5 by the way
is is tempting because i do have a big
threat
yeah it's becoming like a uh
like a choose your own win right choose
your own adventure type thing yeah it's
just winning everywhere but rook to h6
just seems to be like the most the most
precise the most natural yeah the most
followed by immediately the transfer of
the knight to cc yeah we've talked about
being a lazy gym and i don't think this
is an exception might as well all right
going back to the a group
nothing has happened
further than you should the king is
going to have form the game but that's
why but the king was on f4
oh the key is already
this is a funny position because it
looks like you just played king f6
you're making progress yeah but no you
actually just were on f4
and this is another reason this is just
a draw right it's just like i just don't
make any progress once you get here
yeah there's
not much i mean he's going to try but
there's not much i think
i think the trying is done
another player that could potentially
try is you young e and he is trying
and most likely
the trying will be over in this one as
well yeah well the trying is going to be
forever in that game yes
and uh what happened in oh
okay a lot of things have
changed either black is totally fine or
they're totally lost there's not much of
an in between here
right
so there's a very big threat in the
position knight c6 is a huge threat
because you target the knight and you uh
target a7 and i'm just gonna go ahead
and assume that the end games are lost
after knight d5 knight takes f4 like
unclear
but what if i go here
i think i just go knight c7 oh knight c3
uh
okay
let's see but here i take on a seven and
go bishop c7 i think
who don't think that black holds this
ever
maybe you do hold it though 95 already
played
okay that's good and bishop d2 by the
way immediately played now of course you
don't want all our knight to c3
and you want you still want play knight
to c6 c6 is coming so whatever you just
retreat knight c7 how do i defend maybe
like this
well bishop before i take and go knight
c6 and how is that
it's at least dangerous but i have a5 at
the end i have something
so i was thinking about knight c3 but
now you have a5 and i think no and if
you capture the d4 pawn you're probably
just lost after knight c8
like if you go for
knight yeah
because at the end the knight on v6
defends a4
yep yep
but they are playing quite fast so he
played knight to c7 ah are they just
repeating the moves no no the bishop was
on um
i mean right now yeah if you go 97
bishop f4 then yes but that's what he
did in 97 and there's nothing here no
they're just repeating the moves let's
see they repeated at least twice
so knight to c7 what's the ah the idea
is that after knight to c6 i just simply
yes of course yeah you're defining a6
i don't see but this is not
that clear because now you have bishop
to f4 right right and then what is this
ah you just go a5
that's the point now you go e5 yeah
something something if you move once you
don't have empaths on the next move
apparently those are the rules of chess
yeah this is fine i know that ambassador
always has to be played
always always every move right
absolutely so if you see ambassador you
have to play it yeah knight c6 equalizes
in uh
i don't know i feel like white if though
you don't have bishop f4 then there's
nothing here right
might be nothing might be nothing i mean
if you give black a free tempo
i assume they just get out of their
shell right yeah although i don't know
what black's next move is bishop d6
maybe
bishop d6 why not i mean that actually
is quite an important diagonal
because you always harass my knight on
c7 with bishop to f4 yeah i agree with
that
so bishop to d6 and then knight c6 and
then i go a6 and 5.
yeah the funny part is that after king
f1
for example right
bishop d6 bishop f4 ah then you take on
e5 whatever
yeah looks looks equal to me then yeah
yeah all right it might just be
a draw between these players
okay this mirror's not going anywhere
okay savion actually is up upon
savion
up upon in this end game
but just for a second because this is
the one that we were having our eyes on
and uh
oh the jacobian the mishra versus
sakobian
with mishra having a huge time advantage
it's the last eight time advantage but
it's not as huge
on the other hand his position over the
board looks quite tasty
does indeed one minute and 20 seconds by
the way for hacobian right now yeah
jacobian actually has the problems of
the background
made so for example huge problems yeah
if you for example rook takes d4 or
whatever you just take on d4 and rook b8
is made at the end
because he doesn't have h7
so
nice move by the way right to c1 not
only that you want to take on c6 but
actually you want to set up this uh bind
where they're coming to c5 this looks
really bad for black i like what he's
doing yeah i like what mishra is doing
but he's breaking through right now and
what is black's next move that's a good
question you're going to defend this
pawn actually yeah i will take on c6 it
is a free pawn queen b6 i think was
played
let's cover yes
um
all right
seven moves
seven moves to go
it does feel
like
prisoner's telling us that vasquez looks
like he might win sometimes i think our
producer does listen to the show we
we already said that a while ago mr
producer um but that's uh
that's okay but we like we like your
we get a lot of else from from the
producers mostly because they use the
engine but
this time we'll take w
all right queen b6 on the board what do
you what do you suggest here for
michelle what catches your eye
immediately as a move for white here
knight
no but knight to f5 is just knight f5 is
tempting because it hits stuff
immediately yeah but then you start
looking at it and it doesn't feel like
the right one it doesn't feel like it
there's a funny move i was considering
the move bishop f5 yes that's another i
wasn't so sure how you respond to it
so once again i cannot take because you
just take take and i have huge problems
yeah it's still amazing the back rank
i guess measure by five you could just
take we do have a move let's see what
that is
queen h h4 i didn't even see that square
uh
i assume queen e4 is a bit annoying but
i don't know if it's all that annoying
the regular e7 is not hanging because
the knight on d5 is defending it
but it does challenge black to find a
move as well which is what i've been
having trouble with in the last last
couple of moves because
white black species are pretty much as
well placed as they get to be
you do feel like white is setting up
something yeah it feels that a trick is
on the position that white is setting up
some kind of tactical detail
i can't see it and you have 40 seconds
to figure it out yeah the 40 seconds
part is the tough part
i like queen h4 actually it's very cagey
just puts the pressure on each other you
don't even know when it's going to give
dividends yeah
even even a line like taking on before
a5 rook c5 you can start to consider
exactly because right now once you take
on b4 you cannot really capture the
knight because the the recon 7 is
hanging
very good point um and if you do take
with the a pawn if you do take with a
queen you lose this c6 spawn if you take
with the a point then a5 the exchange on
a5 and then rook takes c6 um rook to d7
was played
oh man with only 12 seconds oh man
so much temptation in this position i
just can't make anything work
wait a minute
i'm thinking about bishop to b5 somehow
yeah bishop b5 i wanted to make that
work too h7 is not h7 is not covered if
you give up the bishop
i was trying to make the exact same
tactic work it's funny how grandmasters
were yeah the details yeah the king is
uh i'm not gonna go with safe but they'd
be safe king escapes somehow yeah
wow
now if you go here i just simply go g6
um
and we're being told by
the producer our producer
yeah by our no by the chat we do i do
read the chat once in a while that we
have a chat we have a chat you can
actually join the chat on youtube or
twitch and i'll read it once in a while
you'll read both youtube and twitch i'm
that good wow i am that good that's why
they pay you the big bucks and they say
that um
queen age 4 was actually the engine's
recommendation
uh and that kuni 4 is very spicy here
let's take a look at queen e4 spicy
spicy it's the exact uh words used by
the chat bye that was used by the chad
and by stockfish
g6
okay and then where's the where's the
spice
heaven
spicy that that that's spicy i don't
know if it works but it's spicy
that might work actually maybe thus
so
what if i just take like this no but
quincy sexy picks up the bishop yeah
that's not spicy for me
e6
actually never mind no no no no let me
play like this all right then i'll take
i'm i'm running
i don't know how far you'll run
i'm running
putting on my running shoes
well it's spicy i don't know if it's
good
i mean i have moves i have work f1 f
queen h6 i have ideas but i don't know
if i really want to give up
such a beautiful night
exactly it was a stupid night i think i
go into this variation but the night on
d6
it's so sure i'm gonna part ways with it
yeah
well he's thinking about it uh three
minutes and 20 seconds for mishra pretty
pretty important decision here because
big next five moves yeah we have five
moves
huge moves that will determine
the outcome of this game
yeah we might want to stick here i'll
take a look at the other games on my
other screen uh just so that we know
what's going on actually the savion game
might be it's becoming interesting
i'm not sure how to evaluate the end
game but it's not that interesting you
don't have to go for it
[Music]
we're going to see
with this one just for a couple more
moves i'm really curious to see
what mishra is going to come up with
two minutes and 30 seconds for the
youngster
queen to e4 let's try to make it work
out 100 queen to e4 g6 i mean the only
reason you do that is to take on f7
otherwise
i feel that weakening f6 is not that
important to go back
just like that yeah just like that
here i could take on
d4 with the rock
so if you take with the queen i think i
although i can do that too yeah queen
takes before queen takes b4
i think you can yeah because i do have a
check but not much more than that
we do have a move do we see a central
queen no no rook f1 was played
which
we do not have
engines but it is a logical move it
makes queenie for a ton stronger i'll
tell you that much so what if i take on
where on d4
uh oh you cannot you still cannot take
right so now the bishop is on d3 there's
no point on g6 and now you get checkmate
yeah you gotta made it so quintex d4 is
not possible
rook takes d4 not possible
um
good move asking some immediate
questions i like it very concrete
and for aram he just has to play on
increment this is so hard to do he does
it's so hard to do
queen d8 all right but not queen e4
right this was the first move that queen
before is like begging to be played sure
queen to e4 g6 and now now knight f7 now
this has to be winning come on no way
this is not winning if it was dangerous
with the rook on c1 right with the rook
on f1 it has to be winning
so now king takes f7 is not possible
anymore yeah you have to take back with
the bishop it feels like if you take
with the rook once again
this is just uh
losing yeah for black
so you have to take back with the bishop
but then and i do think we will see
queen two e4 first played
by the youngster big threat right now i
mean you can
you can't allow this queen there no you
cannot allow the queen to drop back to
h7 it looks like this is the win
rook takes d6
oh
that's smart
that's very smart
so do i throw in queen h7
i think you should and the question is
do i even take the rook i probably
should right i think you should
i did lose a lot of positional advantage
i have to say
wait a minute
let's try this yeah that's what i was
saying
that's just like that you have to play
rook d7 otherwise it's just the worst
version
and then do we have anything here like
rook f6 i don't know what that does
something crazy okay something crazy for
sure so what if i take take and then
just
squeeze
you defend with queen of fate or queen
g8 yeah i don't see it
no this doesn't work
i don't think so
he took on d6 he did yes
queen takes d6 came instantaneously
that's a check
but now i'm starting to feel like aram
might be getting back into the game yeah
i mean you'll go g6 next move you'll
you're more or less stabilized right did
he just
does he might have missed rook takes e6
which is well i missed it too i didn't
consider that move it's kind of a
simple move because you just played
queen to d8 you're hinting
at taking on d6 but at the same time you
get distracted by the idea that queen to
d8 actually attacks your queen first
yeah
no i i didn't see any of these moves
at the same time i don't think he did
have any other options
you can exchange on d8 but that doesn't
make too much no i didn't see much maybe
rook form is not precise i don't know
let's see what the chat says that's when
you're seven
by the way um
queen to e5
i gotta say i saw what the chat was
saying about the position
nowhere near what we were thinking
apparently there was some like rook
takes b4 and c6 is hanging i don't know
okay some crazy stuff crazy stuff no
nothing to do with chess crazy stuff
okay so
we are entering this end game
and uh the rooks are also going to be
exchanges
exchanged are they oh because there's
meat yeah right right right so you can
actually
you can't take on a four yeah
then is it yeah yeah
i mean if you have to exchange if you
don't have to exchange the rooks
then i think i don't know but it cannot
be that easy it's pretty bad i don't
think it's easy but it's pretty bad
the thing is you don't have a defensive
who defends c5
it doesn't matter i'm going to take with
the knight yeah
so let's say i just play a moveset such
as g6 and now
and we're being told that sam savion and
jonas beard did draw we kind of expected
that so g6 now i'm actually threatening
to take on a4 you have to yeah let's say
i take take knight takes b4 and bishop
e4 or something no
you have some counter play right
so i just want to keep contact with
opponent a4
all right maybe it's not so easy
i don't think it is yeah maybe not i
mean i'm not saying it's not winning but
but it won't be likely very very close
to it but it's not easy
yeah i i don't know either actually
i don't know either
well
but but we know who's playing for a win
how close to move forward he played g6 i
mean jesus
one more moves and you have to take them
before
i can't imagine not taking on b4 here
yeah it feels like the
before it looks like completely forced
it's a bit annoying that you have this
move uh bishop b3 at the end of b3 yeah
maybe maybe you don't even move the
bishop from d3 you go like for f3 or
something
i really don't want to trade on d3
but now i'm starting to yeah but then
this is
this is what i want to get
is right yeah if i want to if i can
somehow anchor yeah your pawn's not
gonna it's not gonna queen i'll bring my
my king and
i think i'll win eventually i don't know
king ji wants i don't believe you
i do not believe you believe a lot of
things i say
i do not believe you
i don't believe you
here we are
[Music]
this is a weird position yeah yeah but
maybe rook a3 bishop d3 just wins here
rook a3 and then bishop to d3
um
and um
that game as you mentioned alejandro
savion versus beer has finished in a
draw we're not going to talk with any of
those players because we actually have
probably a victor very soon
at that vasquez game yeah what's
happening in that one
could we oh my goodness no this game is
just ah
yeah this game is just over those two
pawns actually cost a bishop
actually probably good technique is to
go h4
i like h4 yeah yeah yeah
h4 at least gains another tempo oh yeah
another pass point actually i don't know
why no no because i go king f6 what do i
play h4 here i play king jay's pick what
am i doing
uh this should be a winning position
100 of the time right
i don't know
i i'm assuming that yes but
so i go bishop b3 and i go bishop
actually i'm not gonna go bishop
it makes no sense to do that i'm gonna
go king f6 what do you do
i don't know i'll push my pawns b5 or
something whatever
i don't think it matters that much
um actually maybe you even want to go
you even go at f4 i think yeah yeah i
think even the segments are lost because
this is a good point there's a good pawn
here
so what you want is basically get this
position yeah look at the pawn on major
although there are a lot of positions
where
there's a lot of positions where you
block with like if you go king e6 bishop
b3s there's already a draw right so you
have to be very careful on how you do
this
yeah
not that easy not that easy still some
work to be done but this should be
winning
yep yeah and this has to be winning i
don't believe
okay
what's happening with
um
jacobson
let's go to that one
brandon jacobson is currently up zero
points from the two points he was up
because that explains how much
compensation joey and charlo had
because he has up zero points now uh
pair of bishops probably not that
relevant considering where the material
is but still pair of bishops
which is not a very good pair of bishops
it's a decent pair of bishops it's not
amazing but it could get better it could
get better yeah this bishop coming to c4
will eventually if we do exchange some
some pieces maybe the rooks yeah it can
get dangerous i'd rather be white
because bishops but
but it's probably pretty equal
well
so how do we do things here
is white to move
do we start with queen to e3 do we try
to go
rook to b5 setting up this pin doesn't
really work because of queen to d1 yeah
maybe you can start with bishop f1
cannot allow that
bishop to f1 really i just really don't
like that i just played bishop to h3
come on
this is what happens in grandmaster
chelsea just a couple of moves ago well
i don't know
i like this
cagey view of zhu zhang chow it seems
like we're spying on him i like this
video behind the wall you see it's a
very funny wall like completely white oh
brando there's something to say about
that there's brandon
you're being told this is the only shot
we have of the entire tournament it's uh
we're picking something
into
the safe space of zhu zhang chow
i like it
all right
what else we have
uh something that we haven't updated in
a while
i still think this is just equal and
they may move 40.
yes
somehow and people lost a piece wait
what
how did that happen
oh my goodness i'm not sure actually how
this happened
well he did lose a piece now
how bad is it that question is i
actually have no idea uh there is one
remaining pawn for white if i manage to
exchange that then that's it it's
technically a draw yeah even though you
still have to prove it he will probably
yeah and i have a feeling
but
how do you get to that point it's not
that trivial it's a good question
and they just made move 4d this is more
4d1 actually
so what if i go rook to a6
or let's try to set up this attack on e7
rook c7
here maybe i go a3 anyway okay
can i let you go eight two
i don't know
maybe not yeah because a2 just
six yeah because a2 wins the rock in
that line
rook 26 now if you go a3 i go bishop c5
well here i go a2
can you do a c3 right
yeah maybe this is enough
maybe the pawns are enough yeah it's
possible the pawns are just enough here
to keep equality
it's hard to believe that this annoying
because you're not losing the a pawn
actually
it's hard to believe that if you have
this annoyance of the pawn that you're
going to be
wait so how do you do it right now yeah
a2 stay tuned then rook d3 same stuff
i don't care about e7 so i just give a
check
and i go up king six whatever
[Music]
i'm king of five
i go back and i just stay
just stay like this stay like that
and you're saying that i actually have
no way to
improve my position
no way
i don't believe this what if i get the
bishop to e5 somehow mm-hmm okay in fact
i'm gonna go bishop to f8 first i'll
i'll make stupid moves until you do that
okay
i'll keep the bishop here sure
you continue making stupid moves sure
i don't want to continue making stupid
moves because you're threatening i'm
going to take that you're going to take
on h7 but
even if i go g5 it's already a draw
right
oh you have g5
well
not sure king d5 don't go king of fire
that'd be funny that would be a tragedy
of sorts but you could go here here here
and now
then we fight this i have a feeling that
this is holdable for black uh i have a
strong feeling of that by the way we do
have a3 on the board and bishop to e3
really
what if a2
oh maybe bishop d2
what a concept nice i like this
what a concept
huh so you cannot actually
you can go kingito also but yeah
perhaps this is even cleaner
that's true
i like this bishop e3 move
okay okay okay okay let's let's not get
ahead of ourselves
just let me exchange the last part
yeah you'll get it let me exchange the
last pawn
will i
e5
e5 important move
to not the uh or e6
all right e6 is nice it's like the
stronger because on e5 you have bishop
g3 yeah e6 easy that's good yeah
we found the draw yay
what the technical draw the technical
draw because then you still have to
suffer for the for the remaining 50
moves yeah okay bishop to e3
um
yeah
it looks like you're gonna lose a two a3
by fours
so you really want to get rid of this
last pawn as quickly as possible there's
no reason to suffer speaking of which
maybe we should try this idea of yours
bishop to d2
because perhaps right now it's not that
easy to exchange just last pawn ah but
now you get ready to exchange it i have
a feeling that this bond isn't surviving
to be quite honest if you just pluck the
parent 82 off the board i'm not even
sure that's winning like i don't know if
it's a draw but i don't guarantee it's
winning
and perhaps this is just the easy easy
drop easy draw you give a check but then
i go up
nothing to be done
yeah and somehow uh
camille's body posture doesn't seem
very confident in a victory either no i
have a feeling that this is technically
a draw how did he lose the piece by the
way
he probably gave it he probably gave it
away right let's see
we're going to drop back a couple of
moves just to see exactly
wow he like legit just said i don't like
my piece
that's an interesting decision because i
don't see anything wrong with bishop f5
very puzzling to me
so i would assume he was afraid of
something like this yeah bishop a1 and
then queen e5 or something
and if you go here i have queen c3 you
actually cannot defend all of all of the
squares
maybe
it's still a little curious right the
decision to just take on g2
oh yeah
oh yeah
it feels more desperate than it had to
be
maybe you were wrong but
that's how it feels to me
we're not wrong
we picked at the engine but but
basically it is the second best move
it does make a draw yes and um yeah the
current position the current position is
just strong yeah we kind of expected
that
sometimes we're right and you actually
have a couple of i guess this is
actually much easier and then e5 yeah
yeah
well you can take the pawn why are we
even thinking of this right
yeah yeah right that's easy that makes
it very easy
okay so this one will probably go
in direction of a draw
what's happening in that checkout game
that we oh my goodness
this does look like chekka
is on the verge of uh victory
yes that being said yes or no
he was already looking in the verge of
victory for a while and this one looks a
bit more complex than it needed to be
maybe i'm wrong though
because i remember the original position
with the rooks being passive and now
okay the rocks are not amazing we left
it off let's just actually go there
remember we've left it out basically
there and i'm not really sure what
progress white's made since
king h1
yeah trying to go to g1
h4
aggressive
h5
so i guess he's weak and black on some
squares and this is one repetition but
of course white will not take the second
they just wanted to make time control
but currently your c3 knight is hanging
i have i have a threat you have a threat
black has a real threat
and if you do go knight takes d5 then
maybe i can exchange the queens yeah
this is already not so clear right not
clear at all no no i take and then i
have some checks
coming to c2 no no no you cannot stop me
from doing that because if you do this
then you just lose i'm not even sure
who's better exactly yeah no i don't
like knight takes d5 so so what do you
do well the good the the key question
will be queen h6 i think queen to h6
either it works or it doesn't now you
cannot take on c3 i think because you
give a check
and then at some point i'll take on c3
like i'll give another check on the dark
square and i'll take one c3
now
the question is does black have a
perpetual at the end
maybe you don't need a perpetual at the
end just take on e3
yeah i mean i have my threats too that's
the thing you're having checkmate
yeah i don't believe in this
so how do you defend
maybe you take first
yeah i just don't know how that helped
me though
and it's a bit scary
yeah this is just i mean i mean it's
still just one check yeah
i mean you can keep chasing me but why
do you want to keep chasing me right
you can go queen g8 here but just
kidding sound
i don't know if there because queen
takes d5 and then i have to calculate
stuff
[Music]
but this looks
well maybe instead of queen jade i just
stick on g6 what am i doing take a pump
for free
oh
yeah why not
let's take it
no you don't want to go on dark squares
because bishop f6 but if you go on the
light squares
i cannot take on f5
right
because if queen takes f5 and rope takes
c3 and
black is winning we are kind of deep in
the rabbit hole but it is actually what
black white is probably looking at
because queen h6 is he must be looking
at this yeah if quidditch doesn't work i
don't know what you do
is there an alternative
i don't see it yeah either you throw in
queen h6 immediately or after h takes g6
but i don't see another move
because recap 2 already tried it was
already played in the game
which will be just a draw by the way
well
why i want to take on g6 first
is that if you start with queen
to h6
rook takes c3 and now you go queen to g7
then when you take on c3 unfortunately
rook takes c3 you don't have queen takes
g6
yeah so once we exchange these two pawns
i will have this extra option
that being said on the other hand you
can take on each time with the check
instead of going cringes you can but we
looked at that right
so we looked at this
now you have to go to h8
you don't have queen g7
you might have queen f7 yeah but that
doesn't help you too much because now i
go up bishop d6
bishop c5 sorry but it doesn't work
no no it doesn't work all right then
maybe maybe chuckle misplayed his hands
maybe checkout just misplayed his hand
because i don't i don't quite see it
what does the engine say he did the
injured zero right yes yeah
yeah yeah something went really wrong
for for white because he was definitely
winning
when we left it off yeah he was
definitely winning he was plus two where
we left it off
and uh vasquez is a big mess still
nursing
since we're cheating and it's the last
five minutes of the show it's probably i
mean it's plus a million okay good yeah
um
by the way
we're not that bad at chess
as you can see mishra and
aram are actually following our
idea yeah
and uh
somehow oparin is still playing
that king is doing the opposite of
progress right
he's still fighting
he's trying to trick him into some kind
of pawning game
there are a couple of photographers
where i actually lost for black yeah the
king's on a1
you go f4
yeah
you know
king on a1 huh
even that's a draw
right so
mishra unclear
smearing oparin has to be a draw yeah
um
right ray rob's in your yang yeah i'm
still betting
still betting stop stopping on the draw
here but there's some
some options this is actually very cute
what ray is doing wait what is he doing
after context alpha queen g5 probably
yeah
yeah but this is enough
he was suffering and it's not like the
cleanest way of having him
i don't know why he's pumps on f5
actually to be honest that's that's a
very good question oh he put it there
he put it there right now
yeah i'm not i'm not sure about this
all right so we do think that uh rey is
suffering but still within a
draw range
yeah
yeah but
it's getting tricky for sure actually
you know what the interesting thing is i
have no idea how to evaluate the
theodore one game i'm not even sure
who's playing over they haven't drawn
they haven't drawn yet no they actually
played out into the same game and i'm
i'm i'm i have a feeling that white
actually um
has
overplayed his hand a little bit
i see
the knight e3 is an issue yeah
knight c3 is a problem
you did get the d-pawn
yeah but who cares
okay
not going anywhere
adipone is kind of stuck
also
how long has been thinking for this move
it feels like he's been thinking the
night takes after night takes a for
forever
yeah i'm not sure i'm not sure i'm not
sure because we don't uh it actually
says right there uh he has 18 minutes
no wait
yeah
yeah six minutes he has six minutes and
30 seconds oh my goodness he's been
thinking he's been thinking for 18
minutes oh my god that's
that's that's
quite irresponsible right after the time
control because you're 41. yeah you jump
from time control to time fresher right
that's because you might actually be
worse
yeah that's the problem you might
actually be worse and by the way i do
think he has actually 11 minutes from
yeah yeah he has 11 minutes the chess
board is a little off but 11 minutes
still not that much time
uh
i mean the most logical move is king e2
and i think you just don't play this for
a win
knight c3 king d3 you just run the king
forward and
and and make the draw and then pray yeah
yeah but the knight is pretty awkward
i'll keep hitting that knight king d5
and your king c6 and that's wait wait
wait wait wait wait time to do it i
think so now it takes a fade
you might still be well let's actually
make sure that we have the board no this
doesn't work
actually
we still don't have the analysis board
oh yeah sorry
there we go
now we have it
so we got
we got all the way to this position from
here
by giving up a pawn and just hunting
this knight down the board
and now i was saying that if you do this
this this then my pawn goes yeah
but
you can just simply take the other guy
yeah and a3 bishop c1 actually works for
uh for white
easy yeah barely but but it does work
well christian we are coming to the
close of our show it's only 90 minutes
per day we try to bring you the
highlights on whatever we can normally
we even get interviews but uh we haven't
had that many games finished today uh
let's leave the uh our viewers with the
pairings for tomorrow
um we usually have a lot more on in
terms of standings and stuff like that
by this point of the day but we don't
have no results almost yeah no no just
one draw
actually only have one one
between uh sam savion and uh jonas beer
and tomorrow we will have quite some uh
some action battles we have ray robson's
versus our own jacobian yonas bier
versus abi manu mishra the two youngest
players in this event benjamin glendora
versus sam savion gregorio parin versus
nicolas theodoru that is a collegiate
match-up mizu vs slua
that's going to be interesting alejandro
tomorrow that'll be fun
he versus elias mirin that's an
interesting one and how about the b
group yeah the big group also has
fascinating struggles uh depending on
how things go i would say that brandon
jacobson could be one of the leaders
tomorrow i also expect uh tamil dragoon
to be one of the leaders tomorrow
they're going to be playing with the
black pieces both one against tigran
harutinian who i think will go down
today uh against jj ali morandi i don't
i really think it's the second time in a
row for a second time in a row he's
having a tournament yeah yeah he's
currently down a piece and no no real
hope there
um antipa playing against joji and ciao
is two of the highest rated players in
the event both of them have been over
2600 so they could even be playing the a
group to be honest and john burke is
playing as nikola chaka and jj who's
probably gonna come off a win will
probably be playing against somebody
that comes from windows as well as i do
think that uh guillermo vazquez from utd
will be dispatching uh john burke today
absolutely a lot of fun games
we're going to be signing off for today
round number three is about to finish
don't forget you can still watch the
games even after this show is over you
can go to leeches you can go to chess24
you will find the summer chess classic
on those platforms and we will be seeing
you tomorrow at the same time 3 30 p.m
central time for the live show and the
games beginning at 1 pm see you tomorrow
with round number four see you tomorrow
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited